50,000 tourists visit Washington DC  everyday my part of the city they never  see the streets now word for the biggest  gang around the ms-13 mr. Cain  responsible Kane is the fastest growing  gang in the United States don't let him  leave  I don't want him having this kind of  life I don't want to be a part of the  game and it drop before you look us and  kind of done you to escape this life  whatever you do don't cry the Lord is  just a kid I know they will risk  everything on one man  listen Yuriko  which other no that loser I want the  brakes and I want the kid I think oh god  oh you first watch it I was like a  father to you I told you like my son  look I'm right do you know what they're  gonna do to you hey what you doing down  here white boy jean-claude Van Damme  we die young  [Music]  you